[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
you should never point it at something
that you don't mean to to destroy an
inside look at the search warrant just
days after alec baldwin fatally shoots a
crew member on the set of his latest
movie and the trial for the death of a
mod arbory law and crime daily host
brian buckmeyer is live in georgia with
the latest on week two of jury selection
plus the state of wisconsin versus kyle
rittenhouse just days before trial is
set to begin the accused kenosha shooter
is back in the courtroom and later hate
on trial jury selection begins in the
civil suit of the 2017 charlottesville
riots lawn crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
and welcome everybody to long crime
daily i'm jesse webber in brian
buckmeyer along with terry austin new
details coming to light about the
shooting by actor alec baldwin that left
an up and coming cinema cinematographer
dead and a director wounded long crimes
anjanet levy's here with the search
warrant that tells part of the story of
what happened
jesse this is the affidavit for that
search warrant it has information in it
from people who saw what happened
including a man who said that alec
baldwin was told the gun he was given
was safe
members of the movie industry gathered
over the weekend to remember helena
hutchins killed on the set of the movie
rust in new mexico the nasa creek
ranches had two people accidentally shot
on a movie set by a prop gun we need
help immediately the 9-1-1 call came
after alec baldwin fired the gun that
killed hutchins and wounded director
joel souza
according to an affidavit for a search
warrant the film's assistant director
dave halls handed the weapon to baldwin
and yelled cold gun meaning the gun did
not have live rounds the affidavit also
states souza told investigators baldwin
was practicing cross-drawing the
revolver when he heard what sounded like
a whip and a loud pop the shooting has
raised questions about the use of guns
on movie sets and how a live round could
make it onto the set
in the stage productions that i've
worked with they have a standard a
standing rule that you never even you
don't point the firearm directly at
the other actor you always aim it to the
side dick stewarwald hasn't worked on a
movie set but is a firearms instructor
in my opinion there should be protocols
involved that
if the
director hands a firearm to an actor and
says cold the actor should check it and
also reply back cold just as as we did
at our training meanwhile sergey zvetnoy
the movie's chief electrician posted on
facebook saying he held hutchins after
she was wounded he wrote the shooting
was the result of negligence and
unprofessionalism questioning the
experience of the armorer hannah
gutierrez who handed the gun to dave
halls he wrote to producers no saved
penny is worth the life of the person
now alec baldwin actually tweeted after
the shooting on friday that he was
cooperating fully with the investigation
and had been in touch with hutchinson's
family the affidavit meanwhile uh talks
about a claim from one of the cameramen
on the set who told investigators that
alec baldwin was very careful with the
gun he even made sure when they were
shooting another scene that a child was
not in the way or nearby the gun when
they were filming the sheriff and the
d.a in santa fe county new mexico where
this happened planned to hold a news
conference on wednesday morning and
we'll let you know what happens jesse
all right thanks and jeanette we're
joined now by co-host terry austin and
trial attorney bernardo villalona
bernardo clearly something went wrong
there was a mistake but the question is
could someone face criminal charges
baldwin anyone else and if so what could
those charges be
absolutely jesse this is definitely a
sad case and a sad case that's been
heard throughout the country now about
this sad mistake that took place so what
we have to distinguish is whether there
will be criminal charges or whether
there will be a civil lawsuit civil law
so highly likely i see that definitely
that the victims in this case would
definitely prevail in regards to a
criminal case i see no criminal
liability in regards at least to alec
baldwin because he was under the
impression that the gun was a cold gun
meaning that it was not loaded so
there's no reason he would have had that
the gun was loaded or would have acted
in a reckless manner had the gun uh had
he known that the gun was loaded you
know terry we've seen something like
this happen you know with brandon lee
and the crow i mean after this how high
profile is do you think that this
incident will result in maybe stricter
regulations for handling guns on film
sets moving forward
i do jesse i think that there will be
more stringent industry standards right
now it's not regulated by the federal
government but the industry really does
have standards in place to prevent this
type of accident and they make sure that
there are no live ammunition on the set
and that they refrain from pointing a
firearm at anyone unless you are aiming
away from that individual you're never
supposed to place your hand or finger on
that trigger unless it's time to
actually point it and you're supposed to
be thoroughly brief and get an
opportunity to actually look down the
barrel of that gun so i definitely think
there will be some increased scrutiny
after this and janet real quick i heard
there was some information about
assistant director dave halls and safety
concerns what can you tell us about that
yeah cnn was reporting that there had
been complaints about dave halls going
back to 2019 involving two different
productions these were complaints that
were apparently levied against him
involving safety concerns with
firearms and pyrotechnics so that was
from a member of the union that
represents the prop makers and she had
issued a statement to cnn discussing
those concerns
wow so we're going to continue to
monitor what happens in that situation
but
it looks like something went wrong and
there's probably a lot of blame to go
around we'll continue to moderate
turning now to florida where we're told
that brian laundry's parents left their
family home to mourn privately following
the discovery of his remains the laundry
family attorney tells long crime network
that roberta and chris laundry left
their northport home to mourn a funeral
will not be held for the 22 year old
last week laundry's remains were found
in florida's carlton reserve following
his disappearance in september laundry's
manner of death came back as
inconclusive but now a forensic
anthropologist will study the remains to
determine how laundry died
laundry's fiance gabby petito went
missing in august after the two traveled
cross country in their van her remains
were found a week after laundry
disappeared and authorities say she died
from strangulation with little
information about the circumstances of
petito's death authorities say now that
crime scenes dna evidence and phone
records could help solve the case
still ahead on law and crime daily the
kenosha shooter back in court what you
can expect from the trial set to begin
next week but first a live look of what
is happening on the ground in georgia in
the trial for the death of a mod arbory
our own brian buckmeyer brings us the
latest news out of jury selection
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
we are going to make sure that we find
justice in this case the three men
charged will now stand trial i told him
stop stop stop till he hit me i had
nothing to do
nothing else i could do you're a
pacifier coming through not necessarily
that's my son that shot him i was at the
back of the truck
starting october 18th watch live capital
gavel coverage on the law on crime
network
[Music]
and welcome back everybody monday marks
the start of week two in the jury
selection for the trial of the death of
a mod arbory father and son duo gregory
and travis mcmichael and neighbor
william roddy brein are on trial for the
death of 25 year old ahmad arbury in
february 2020 arbory was reportedly
jogging near his brunswick georgia home
when the mcmichaels began to tail him in
a pickup truck eventually travis
mcmichael shot him claiming self-defense
brian followed along in his own vehicle
and recorded the incident on his cell
phone the video was later released
causing a national uproar arbory a black
man was unarmed at the time of his death
all three defendants were indicted on a
federal hate crime and face several
state charges including malice murder
felony murder and aggravated assault
outside the courthouse on tuesday civil
rights activists called for respect for
arbory's father during the course of the
trial
this hostility towards mr
really needs to stop
i mean i know that he's trying to
represent his client but that doesn't
mean you get hostile to a family member
of somebody who has been killed
that is so inappropriate and i have been
greatly distressed by it because i've
heard him lie before
saying a fact is not true
and it happened again this morning
for the latest on the trial we turn now
to long crime daily host brian buckmeyer
who's live in georgia outside the glenn
county courthouse brian it's good to see
you it seems like jury selection for
this trial could take quite a while so
how are things looking today as we begin
week two of jury selection
how's it going jesse yes jury selection
is looking like gonna take quite some
time to complete but it started off with
a bit of drama this morning as a
prosecutor and defense began questioning
jurors one defense attorney said as a
potential juror walked out an
african-american man that mr aubry that
is
mod aubrey's father gave a bit of a head
nod to this juror now we actually had an
opportunity to speak with mr aubry and
two representative from the
transformative justice coalition and
they spoke about how that was somewhat
hurtful and that that never occurred and
that they're trying to maybe plant the
seed that mr aubry is doing something
improper also heard other questions that
they kind of questioned asking about
what church people go to what would they
want from a juror if they were accused
of this crime but at the end of the day
mr aubry spoke about the jury selection
process thus far both about how the
defense was conducting himself sometimes
not liking it as much as he would prefer
but also talking about the prosecution
how they were beginning to talk about
the case in a way that he was proud of
and also finding that he was very
confident in their overall caring of
this case brian you know there's these
issues in terms of jury selection people
who know the defendants whether or not
they've already formed an opinion about
this case now we haven't heard this yet
but could a motion for a change of venue
be on the table if we continue to run
into these issues of finding a jury in
this case
i don't think so yet jesse i don't think
we're at that point and the reason why i
say that is why we are having a lot of
trouble with jurors being struck one was
very interesting i found today he said
that he's actually knows uh and is
related to mr aubry the father vermont
arbory and that william rhodey brian
sold him lawn equipment so we talk about
how close this community is uh it's very
interesting to see how they do know each
other but still the question is whether
or not they can be unbiased whether or
not they can put aside what they know
and judge this case based on the facts
and evidence and not want to hear
outside the court yeah i was surprised
to hear from jason sheffield who
represents travis mcmichael and says he
feels confident in getting a jury and
that you know that an impartial jury to
say the least that'll be interesting to
see how the continuation of jury
selection goes and how long it's going
to go for brian thanks so much i hope
you don't mind me keeping the seat warm
for you until you get back thanks so
much brian
over now to california the husband
accused of contacting spell casters to
avoid a divorce now pleads not guilty to
his wife's murder all this as an arrest
warrant states that 40-year-old larry
mayate choked his wife until she passed
out and googled date rape drugs before
she went missing thirty-nine-year-old
may mayate who went by the nickname maya
went missing from her chula vista home
in january a body has never been found
last tuesday her husband was arrested
for her murder on thursday he plead not
guilty to one count of first degree
murder and another count of illegal
possession of an assault weapon
according to the arrest warrant larry
maiate murdered his wife after she saw a
divorce in a press conference the san
diego county district attorney says that
the marriage was a quote toxic
relationship and that larry had
contacted so-called spell casters that
would magically erase their marital
problems well right now maya tay is
being held without bail and we're going
to see if he tries to cast any more
spells in this case but coming up on law
and crime daily four years after the
deadly riots in charlottesville virginia
jury selection is underway in the case's
civil trial plus kyle rittenhouse back
in the courtroom in just one short week
before his trials to begin what to
expect as the long awaited proceedings
begin that's next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to long crime delay
everybody accused kenosha shooter kyle
rittenhouse is back in court this is
just one week before jury selection is
set to begin in his trial rittenhouse is
charged with the deaths of joseph
rosenbaum and anthony huber from the
august 2020 protest that followed the
jacob blake shooting officials say that
the teenager wielded a rifle at the
protesters but his defense team claims
that rittenhouse was acting in
self-defense that night on monday
attorneys for the prosecution and
defense went back and forth debating
over a witness the defense planned to
call officer amanda franco who took a
statement from kyle rittenhouse written
house ahead of the shooting both sides
also argued over whether the jury needs
to hear expert testimony from a use of
force expert rittenhouse's trial is
slated to begin on november 1st okay
let's talk about this so bernarda this
will likely be the last time that we see
written house before next week's trial
what can we expect heading into jury
selection in this very highly
anticipated case
well the decision that the judge makes
in regards to whether use of force
expert will be able to testify on behalf
of the defense is going to be very huge
the defense is going to have to
structure their jury selection depending
on whether you the force acts or will be
allowed to testify because technically
if the defense is able to call a use of
force expert to testify about why why
ridden house took the actions that he
did then kyle rittenhouse will not need
to testify on his own behalf however if
the use of force expert is not allowed
to testify then cal ring else will have
no no other issue is them to testify
before the grand jury to i'm sorry
before the jury to determine whether he
actually acted in self-defense and
whether he was justified well terry do
you think kyle rennhaus will be able to
successfully claim self-defense here
that is really the key question jesse
and under wisconsin law you have the
right to use deadly force for
self-defense or defense of others but
you have to reasonably believe that you
will be preventing your imminent death
or great bodily harm and so the question
here was this reasonable so i do think
experts should come in and talk about
that the video is going to be key we're
going to be able to see what exactly
happened if that gets into the trial and
also what his state of mind was yeah and
with three
victims here it comes to question was it
self-defense all across the board or
maybe just with one victim we'll wait
and see it's definitely a try to watch
well the man convicted of murdering
michael jordan's father will remain in
prison after he was denied parole last
friday the parole commission denied
daniel greene early release it was the
first time in 28 years that he was
eligible you might recall that green and
his co-defendant larry demery were
convicted of james jordan's murder in
1996. the pair have been filing motions
for appeals ever since the nba star's
father was missing for weeks before his
body was found badly decomposed nearly
60 miles away from where he was last
seen sleeping in his car green has
maintained his innocence since 1993
claiming that he helped dispose of
jordan's body after demary had killed
him during an attempted robbery demery
was granted parole last year and he will
be released from prison in 2024
when we come back four years since the
deadly protest in charlottesville
virginia and the civil trial finally
begins what victims of the 2017 riots
are calling for and what's at stake for
the defendants
and welcome back jury selection has
wrapped in florida for the man who's
charged with the murder of lieutenant
debra clayton markeith lloyd was
previously sentenced to life in prison
for the murder of his pregnant
ex-girlfriend shaw day dixon and while
the run for that killing authorities say
lloyd fatally shot officer debra clayton
while she was in his pursuit in 2017.
prosecutors are now seeking the death
penalty for this murder last friday loyd
asked the judge if he could represent
himself during the trial something he
also requested during his first murder
case he claims that quote things aren't
getting done and it's my life on the
line the judge denied lloyd's request
jury selection has lasted over two weeks
after nearly hundreds of jurors had been
narrowed down to 60 and the final 12
jurors and four alternates were chosen
monday afternoon
over now to virginia jurors will decide
whether the unite the right rally
organizers conspired a violent uprising
in the deadly riots the so-called unite
the right rally happened back in august
2017 when white supremacist groups
gathered to demonstrate in
charlottesville virginia all this was in
response to the removal of confederate
symbols by local governments that
followed the charleston church shooting
in 2015. now the protesters marched
through charlottesville chanting phrases
like quote jews will not replace us and
blood and soil virginia state police
eventually proclaimed the gathering to
be an unlawful assembly hours later a
self-identified white supremacist rammed
his car into a crowd of counter
protesters one woman died and dozens of
others were injured two virginia state
troopers also died in a helicopter crash
that was assisting with public safety
now four years after the deadly riots
the civil trial began on monday the nine
plaintiffs including town residents and
counter protesters who were injured
during that event the lawsuit states
that the organizers planned in advance
to quote intimidate harass incite and
cause violence to people based on their
race religion ethnicity and sexual
orientation opening statements are
expected to begin on wednesday and the
trial is reported to last until november
19th okay so bernarda we already saw the
federal trial in 2018 that produced two
life sentences for james alex fields
junior the man who ran his car into the
crowd what to gain now by going in the
civil direction with the civil trial
so right now with the civil trial what
it's doing jesse is that is sending a
message hate is on trial the first
amendment is on trial by taking this
case on a civil trial what it's hoped to
do is to actually bankrupt organizations
such as these that like to incite riots
that end up being harm to other people
so that is the hope in terms of
deterrence of organizations like these
that spill hate speech tend to
bankrupt them and buy bank runs than
them then we get rid of them
so terry i saw something a little
unusual the complaint in the case cites
the ku klux klan act what do the
plaintiffs need to prove under that act
you know it's a reconstruction-era law
so it's a very old law and it was really
designed to halt the ku klux klan after
the civil war and you can sue under that
law for damages and you have to allege
conspiracy and so in order to
prevail you have to show that there was
an agreement between at least two people
and that there was a common act and so
what the plaintiffs have to do here is
to show that they conspired and that
this was foreseeable and there was some
chatter about using a car to kill people
so i think they could argue that this
was foreseeable and frankly they have
about 5.3
terabytes of digital evidence so it
should go well well it's an interesting
legal argument it's going to be
definitely a case to follow bernarda
terry thank you so much everyone out
there thanks for joining us here on long
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you